Ronaldo got benched
son
can you just tell us if he's good or not
yo I think I [ __ ] know Portugal might
have been better without him right my
feeling is like he came in the second
half against Morocco right
yeah no goals no nothing could have
saved his team didn't [ __ ] he's going
less goals objectively like if you look
at the data over his whole career he's
scoring the kind of goals he was scoring
when he was like 22 per season adjusted
for like time and [ __ ] I saw a graph
today and like when he was in his early
30s he was like scoring when Mark does
research Doug I did a little research
you know I mean okay World Cup got me
inspired bro okay so there's another
part of this where you're like do you
just let him play his last World Cup
even if it's at the detriment of your
team no
because I think Ronaldo would even if he
had to choose rather have a World Cup on
his resume with less contribution than
more contribution and never have the
World Cup because in 50 years they're
just going to look at his resume and
it's going to say World Cup or not let
me ask you a question do you think Kobe
would say this feel the same way
if Kobe never had a title
would he accept a lesser role I think he
would at the end of his career
do you truly believe that I truly do if
he never had a title because we're
looking at Kobe with more championships
than Shaq when he's winding down his
career and then he's like I don't give a
[ __ ] what y'all do my resume is set this
team is not good we're not winning a
championship time Mike even if I time I
can get a sixth ring nobody's gonna
think I'm better than him so he would
have been like let's and maybe if they
had a shot at a ring maybe he would have
said look let's I'll play a few less
minutes I want to have as many
championships as Michael maybe
definitely if he didn't have one my
feeling is I don't think that he could
ever accept that he wasn't the best
player out there
so he would believe that the best chance
of his team winning is if he was on the
floor maybe and and I feel like
regardless if that's true or not
Ronaldo's the same
knowing absolutely nothing about Ronaldo
I'm assuming that they have a similar
kind of killer instinct which a lot of
these great athletes have yeah and they
compare them to the most I think fair
and it's just like there's no way you're
gonna believe that you've fallen off now
on some level maybe Kobe somewhere would
be like okay I'm not as dominant as I
used to be but he's also looking as
teammates he's going I'm giving every
one of these guys buckets like to this
day I bet Jordan is like I could play
with these guys there was that story
that came out that was crazy dude that
was Chris Charlotte whatever the [ __ ]
they're called they're the Hornets again
or the Pelicans
they were the Bobcats yeah
Pelicans so it's like come on bro so
it's okay I'm gonna keep talking through
it so we don't make fun of you for your
embarrassing uh well the fact you're
saying it means that you're making fun
of me oh yeah you're right my bad okay
come on so my bad I [ __ ] up on that
one so uh so
he basically says the uh the [ __ ]
Bobcats were losing he made all the
players on the first team take off his
shoes so anybody who's wearing Jordans
had to take off Jordans you weren't
allowed to play in Georgia 2010 or 2012.
he ended up playing on the second team
and then beating the first team during
practice so it's like that's the
mentality that's never going to leave
you now can he do this every single day
he can't play every single game there's
no way he could do it but I wonder if
Cristiano Ronaldo's like yeah okay maybe
I'm scoring less yeah okay these things
are happening whatever but he's never
thinking that there's another person
that's better on the team what do you
think you're the soccer fan here I like
soccer for the record yeah okay
Jesus you know everything about soccer
but I'm saying if they're building the
attack through one guy and he's not
delivering in the way that he used to be
delivering yeah do we pull him off and
then build the attack through different
players or build a new way to attack and
if that's the case then he's got to come
off but how to use level with arguably
one of the greatest players of all time
and say hey your role is going to be a
lot different and we're actually going
to go through this guy or you're just
not going to be on the field at all and
then if he's being a diva about it is
like nah [ __ ] that then it's affecting
the morale of the whole team yeah
they're like hey our star like our guy
is true now throwing like a fit in the
locker room if this is what's happening
after the game against South Korea he
like stormed off the field and like
didn't say hi to like do like The
Cordial ceremonial thing the manager
actually handled it well that was during
the group match right before they played
Switzerland got it and so yeah that's
why they benched him right that's the
way I understood it they haven't like
fully come out and said well they didn't
bench him because he was washed they
benched him because he was being a
little [ __ ] so they subbed them off
right at the end of the game and I think
it's a mixture of things he's not
performing at his high of a level where
he can just do whatever he wants and
then secondly he's affecting the morale
of the team if he was at his Peak he
gets away with that [ __ ] problem and I
actually think the manager based again I
don't know much but based on what I do
know seemed like he handled it well in
that he bench Ronaldo for the one game
then the second game he's sitting right
first half it's 1-0 they're down second
half it's like all right man go in there
see if you can make something happen
yeah you're not gonna tell me I didn't I
because you can't be the manager set
Ronaldo whole match and then y'all
didn't score and y'all lost shutout so I
put you in the second half go see if you
can make something happen and you
couldn't but now Ronaldo and the Ronaldo
fans can be like yo if he was in the
whole game we would have won no why
because he's you had 45 minutes ago the
guy that replaced him the next game yeah
so I think the coach feels Vindicated
the coach is like look I made this
change and my man went off yeah
Ronaldo's thinking if I was playing this
game I would have scored five goals yeah
why don't you get me the ball like he's
getting the ball I'm sure that's what a
great athlete thinks even if he's being
ridiculous because like you're saying
yeah you have to because that type of
mentality is going to lead to success
I guess what I'm saying is like if
Portugal wasn't
uh a favorite I don't know if they were
a favorite against Morocco they were no
no I mean in general like in the
Worldcom General nobody had Portugal
going all the way right I mean but
they're dominant and like they have one
of the greatest players ever so I guess
in my mind I'm just like
like France I'm not [ __ ] with that
lineup because they are probably the
favorites going into it
Portugal nobody's thinking they're gonna
win to think that they maybe do okay but
they're not guaranteed to win
what I'm going is let Ronaldo play every
single game of his last World Cup yeah
and then maybe this guy can produce some
magic
that's what I'm thinking if you were
you know top three teams maybe they were
thinking that we're gonna make it out
then don't play any games play the best
possible [ __ ] players Etc but it's
almost like Kobe with his last season
it's like nobody thought the Lakers
gonna win the championship so you let
that [ __ ] play every single game
despite whether it's good or bad for the
team 100 agree because I think it don't
they look at Messi the same way they
look at Ronaldo
Messi yeah buddy they're both at the end
of their career yeah they're like not
producing as highly as they were during
their Prime and Messi played every
single minute of the game so I feel like
still scoring goals and he's if he's
talking [ __ ] is not on his own teammates
he's going off on the other team's coach
the other team the other referee you
heard the last match talking cash [ __ ]
yeah he was going crazy yeah it's like
bench and LeBron like you don't do that
yo it's yeah
but again producing like he was you
don't bench LeBron we're just Outsiders
so it's so easy for us to say yeah
because we just want to see the the only
[ __ ] we know
that's a big part yeah it's like it's
like when you go see a band and they
start playing their new [ __ ] you're like
nah we ain't coming here for the new
album yeah you know what I mean like I
got this unreleased song You better
release it
like I've come here for released yeah
and Cristiano Cristiano Ronaldo is the
[ __ ] hits